Primerica is middle America's financial
services provider our businesses around
the kitchen table conversation I'm
talking about life insurance it's not a
comfortable conversation to have with
somebody and usually it's a big life
event that that you know initiates this
conversation so it needs to have this
human element it has to this human touch
so one of our major catalysts for
application modernization was our legacy
applications so with the institutional
knowledge disappearing in our industry
it's very difficult to find folks with
specific skillsets to support those
legacy applications we actually went and
asked IBM how do we get off of IBM
technologies and onto IBM technologies
well we had heard through our IBM rep
that there was a group of people that
could help us with our modernization
strategy a very forward-thinking a very
uninhibited team within IBM and the
cloud garage is really the answer it was
about technology innovation it was show
us and teach us how to modernize our own
applications on IBM's latest and
greatest technologies there were several
aha moments whenever we were engaged
with the IBM garage but I say the one
with the most impact was really whenever
we saw our first legacy application
stood up in a containerized environment
on IBM cloud private that showed us that
it was actually possible that it was
done quickly and that we could keep
using all of those great applications
that we've had for many years to come